it is so obvious that former Republican
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie is by
far the best Republican candidate
running for president this year he is at
least for now not doing the anti-woke
stuff he's willing to go after failed
twice impeached once indicted former
president Donald Trump he sounds like a
normal person although we obviously have
policy disagreements and the Maga people
don't want him we're going to look at
clips of Chris Christie's Town Hall that
he did yesterday announcing his
candidacy running against Trump and it's
after watching this town hall it's
clearer than ever to me if I were voting
in the Republican primary if I knew a
republican would be president it would
be Chris Christie that I would support
and this is not about glorifying or
glamorizing the guy
but he's willing to tell what should be
pretty uncontroversial truths he doesn't
equivocate when he's asked about Trump
and say well I'm not talking I'm here
focused on me not on Trump no he
understands you've got to go against
Trump and this was a very solid Town
Hall if more Republicans were like Chris
Christie we would have a much better
country than we do with people like
Trump and Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert and these sorts of
lunatics here's Chris Christie going
right after Trump he's not afraid
a lonely
self-consumed
self-serving
mirror hog
is not a leader well let me be clear
in case I have not been already
the person I am talking about
who is obsessed with the mirror
who never admits a mistake who never
admits a fault
and who always finds someone else and
something else to blame for whatever
goes wrong but finds every reason to
take credit for anything that goes right
is Donald Trump
and if we don't have that conversation
with you
we don't deserve
to ask for your vote I completely agree
Nikki Haley won't even say anything
other than well I'm a woman and I'm
younger and I'm a person of color and
Tim Scott says there's going to be a
contrast but I'm not making this about
other candidates now an audience member
during this town hall asked Chris
Christie if Trump's indicted and your
president will you pardon him when
DeSantis was asked about this he
basically said yes Chris Christie on the
other hand is saying almost certainly
not with a little bit of equivocation
but almost certainly not if Donald Trump
is indicted and you become president
will you pardon him
well I I have to tell you the truth
I can't completely answer that until I
know what he was charged with and
convicted of
okay so but but I'm not going to dodge
the answer okay
but I will tell you as a prosecutor
if I believe someone has gotten a full
and fair trial in front of a jury of
their peers
and especially someone in public life
who committed those crimes
when they held the public trust I can't
imagine pardoning them okay so I'm
hearing that as almost certainly not not
a perfect answer but a thousand times
better than the answer given by Ron
DeSantis Chris Christie did head on face
what he considers the biggest mistake of
his political career which was that some
of the people working for him had that
insane situation where they diverted
traffic off the George Washington Bridge
as political punishment I believe it was
to the mayor of Fort Lee New Jersey
although I don't now remember 100
obviously Chris Christie is going to
minimize the degree to which he was the
one at fault but he's taking
responsibility I just wish more
Republicans talked this directly because
they just you can't get a straight
answer out of almost any of these clowns
the biggest mistake I made in public
life was that I put a few people into a
position of authority at the Port
Authority of New York Jersey who went on
a frocking detour to divert traffic off
the George Washington Bridge
without telling me without me knowing
anything about it they used my power and
my authority to play a fraternity prank
and it cost me a lot
it cost me credibility
it humiliated me publicly
and I should have never put those people
in that position
it's the biggest mistake I made there
you go the biggest mistake uh Chris
Christie also addressing the claim by
Donald Trump that if he were president
he would end the Russia Ukraine war in
24 hours Chris Christie pointing out the
way he would end it is by giving
everything to Russia and now I heard him
say if we made a president again
he would settle the Ukraine war in 24
hours did you hear that one that's a
beauty that's really in a career of
complete falsehoods
that makes the top five
but let's give him the benefit of the
doubt let's say Donald Trump could
settle it in 24 hours let me tell you
how he would he'd give Ukraine to Russia
and he said it
he said it on television he said it's
here and he said look Russians don't
wind up with Ukraine anyway so what's
the difference
that's how he settled in 24 hours he
calls Solinski and say hey guess what
time to raise the Russian flag up on the
pole we're out of here there are no
other Republican candidates willing to
say this they just aren't willing to do
it whether they believe it or not I
don't know but Chris Christie is at
least willing to say this stuff and it
is abundantly clear to me that there is
going to be one guy on the stage with
Trump if they get that far who is not
going to be pulling punches everybody
else is pulling punches Chris Christie
is not pulling punches here is Chris
Christie breaking out the Trump
impression on day one of his campaign it
was a mistake
in 2016 not to confront Donald Trump
early true because I knew that so much
of what he said was complete baloney
like I knew it I'm going to build the
greatest most wonderful wall
across the entire Mexico border and
Mexico is going to pay for it well like
I knew as someone who had governed that
that was complete bull but I was like
people aren't going to believe that
they're not going to believe that
mistake
it was a mistake and uh he's completely
correct and he points out other bogus
claims that Trump has made he talks
about debt and deficit here and again
this isn't the Chris Christie
cheerleading segment it's there is
something notably different about Chris
Christie compared to all the other
candidates and how they are relating to
the issues notice that there isn't any
anti-woke stuff here at least he's
talking about moderately real issues
here he is about national debt and
pointing out Trump's lies there as well
the reason this is going to be different
this time sir is because at least one of
us
is gonna call him on the fact
that eight years ago he stood on the
stage of New Hampshire and said he was
going to balance the budget in four
years
and he left
with the biggest deficit of any
president in American history he said
he was going to eliminate the national
debt in eight years
Trump did say that he added three
trillion dollars
to the national debt in four years so a
very very strong Town Hall overall it'll
be interesting to see whether this moves
the needle at all in terms of polling
which right now is not great for Chris
Christie one last
clip from this Chris Christie made the
claim during the town hall that if Biden
had been running against someone
different in 2020 Biden would have lost
that Biden was a poor candidate but one
because so many people so acutely
dislike Donald Trump and it's certainly
possible that that is true it's possible
let me be very clear I am going out
there to take out Donald Trump but
here's why I want to win
and I don't want him to win
and guess what if you put DeSantis and
Haley and Pence
and Tim Scott
that's it I'll stop there
on true serum they tell you the same
thing here's the difference here's the
difference you have to put me on true
serum to tell you
okay so that's why there are not
multiple Lanes to the Republican
nomination
that is a political science professor's
dream
there is one lane yep it's the
Republican nomination and he's in front
of it and if you want to win you better
go right through him
because let me guarantee you something
from knowing him for 22 years everybody
he gonna kind of go through me
and he's going to try to go through Ron
and Nikki and Tim and anybody else who
stands in his way all right so Chris
Christie gets it Chris Christie
understands what's going on Trump's not
a good candidate but Trump is leading
the Republican nomination the path to
the nomination is through Trump it's not
taking your two percent like Nikki Haley
or sorry four percent like Nikki Haley
or two percent like Tim Scott and just
talking about how you're going to be
positive and whatever uh the path is
through Trump and the question is
whether Chris Christie will be able to
do it I don't know I'm curious to see
what polling looks like in two weeks in
the meantime all sorts of people
reacting to Chris Christie's candidacy
just by talking about his weight
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description